of talks for the afternoon so starting
off with a survey from Peter and Kunal
on privacy and Security in Federated
learning and just a heads up if anyone
is live streaming the scent part of this
will not be live streamed so if you see
it turn off that's not a technical
difficulty that is that's on on purpose
so
um but just just a heads up for that and
I think since we're running a little bit
behind I'll just pass things over to
Peter sounds great yeah thank you all
for attending
I'm going to start for the first 20
minutes and then hand it off to Canal uh
so let me
listen cool so so we all have seen this
before today and even before that uh in
Federated learning there's a lot of
factors from the client devices that
have the data to the server that's
orchestrating the competition back and
forth to the engineer that requests the
competition and finally to the large
Fleet of devices on which we're going to
deploy the output of this computation
whether it's a model or analytic
um so there's a lot of actors and if we
want to think about privacy one of the
very reasonable questions to ask what
does each actor in the system have
access to
what does each actor see in terms of
information all right so does the device
see the server the network the deployed
model the release model metrics uh
checkpoints to the engineer and that
that can at least you know um be a place
where we can start thinking about
privacy questions and leakage and so on
and so forth
so
you know privacy is very uh complex it's
not one thing it's not a a scalar it's
not binary it's a multi-dimensional
multi-faceted thing it means different
things to different people and we're
only now converging on some principles
that separate some concerns and you know
this is something that at Google our
team has uh put together over the years
and I'd like to share it with you so we
think of privacy as divided into three
layers things that are uh roughly you
know given to the user uh and this ties
very nicely to Katrina's talk earlier
today uh this is about
transparency and user-centric control to
tell the user precisely what's being
computed on their data to give them the
freedom to choose not to participate if
they don't want to and to tell them how
we're protecting their privacy and then
again they would have more uh controls
and knobs so this is forward-looking
transparency
and then there's uh what I'm going to
focus on in this overview which is like
privacy knobs for the platform itself
encoding data minimization and uh
outputs that provide individual privacy
so we'll dive into those uh but then
finally one critical piece of the
Privacy story is uh how do we verify and
falsify claims so if somebody tells you
I'm using this and that technology
whether it's some crypto or differential
privacy technology how can you Empower
them to be able to falsify those claims
if you have bugs or you're lying about
what you're doing
and so really in order to think of
privacy you need to try to put it all
together
um and you know one thing Federated
learning does really well is data
minimization it's essentially ensures
that uh data collection is done in a
very focused manner for the specific
task and not arbitrarily uh for anything
and everything and we're just going to
scrape anything any signal we can get
our hands on
um from a device and we're going to try
to limit access to the data at all
stages as you saw earlier you know
there's an engineer that's requesting
that computation they can only see
certain select checkpoints not the whole
thing and the server can only see also a
few updates from participating clients
so it does that really well this minimal
retention early aggregation focused
collection
you can see it here as well how you know
we're minimizing data exposure we're
doing focused updates it's Anonymous and
ephemeral updates on the server we
delete those updates uh we immediately
aggregate them and we only uh do limited
release and finally only one deployment
at scale so that's that's the one thing
that I think Federated learning uh
brings uh front and center
but you know something that is critical
as we also saw earlier today is we need
to make sure that whatever we are giving
whether it's to the server or to the
engineers and finally deploying uh
releases outputs that provide individual
privacy provable individual privacy and
a lot of us have worked on differential
privacy in one way or another and that's
really going to be the secret sauce here
so what is this about we want to make
sure that the released output of a
computation does not reveal much about
an individual user something unique or
personal to that individual user so
aggregate statistics including model
parameters when released to an engineer
or Beyond they should not vary
significantly based on whether or not a
particular user's data was used in the
aggregation
and so ideally what we want is uh
something like this we want to give some
privacy guarantees with respect to the
server and then we want those privacy
guarantees to get stronger and stronger
as the surface attack gets bigger and
bigger so here maybe there's tens of
people who have access to the raw logs
of the server in a company but then
there's many Engineers who can request
many computations so the surface of
attack is bigger and therefore we need
stronger privacy guarantees and then add
deployment we're going to take the
output and deploy it at scale on many
millions of devices so the surface of
attack is even bigger so so that's kind
of something that we would like to
realize and the way to achieve this and
we're nowhere near achieving it today in
my opinion uh but you know we have done
some uh progress on this front is by
combining uh various Technologies so we
can combine encryption multi-party
computation secure aggregation and
um all different flavors of differential
privacy that we're going to touch on and
even like you know auditing uh things
like membership inference attack and
secret share attacks so combining all
these things together can allow us to
talk about what we're giving in terms of
privacy with respect to each actor in
the system
and so that's that's really important
and so on this front we're going to rely
on you know a way to relax the trust
assumptions that we place on the server
that's orchestrating these computations
and there's really three main ways we
can achieve that so one way is by
relying on some sort of a trusted third
party or a shuffling party so if we have
instead of one server two non-collutic
servers and you know they can work
together but they don't collude
maliciously together
um then you know we can strengthen the
Privacy guarantees and we can uh we we
can also um you know have beautiful
trade-offs and this is something that
Kunal is going to talk about in the
second part of this overview talk and
then another technology that's growing
in popularity and also in practice as
I'm seeing uh is the use of trusted
execution environments where you know we
have uh the the hardware is isolated
from the rest of the system and
everything on memory is encrypted when
you know we load it and we compute on it
there's uh encryption and decryption
that happens with uh the possibility of
doing remote attestation and verifying
to the user that we're indeed running
the computations we promise to be
running so that's a very promising
technology it still has some issues with
scale but it's improving by the day and
then finally relying on cryptography to
do something like secure aggregation so
this is a form of a multi-party
computation protocol and that's
something I will try to overview briefly
in this part of the of the talk
okay but you know even before we dive
into these complex systems where we're
combining crypto secure hardware and DP
even if we just want to talk about DP
itself the definition I'm sure a lot of
you are very familiar with it you know
it says that if I train the model on two
adjacent data sets the outputs should
look a lot alike statistically they
should be close in some sense the
Epsilon Delta sense
um but one thing that's lesser uh kind
of uh getting attention is the notion of
this adjacency by how much should these
two data sets differ are they deferring
by one training example or more so this
unit of privacy is often overlooked and
that's something that we really want to
draw people's attention to because it
really translates to
um you know what is that we're providing
or protecting from so this this unit of
privacy can take various values if you
want it could be an application of
language models it could be just a
single token so we can get something
like a token level DP the two data sets
only defer by a single token or it could
be a single training example which is a
sequence of tokens and that's the
classical example level DP that is often
used in a lot of the research papers
that you see centralized machine
learning plus DP but you can go into
even you know higher units of privacy
which is like paragraph level document
level or even user level and
organization level and this again ties
very nicely to some of the talks we saw
earlier today especially Zack's talk
when he talked about user level DP and
group level DP for institutions or or
organizations and you have to notice
that these are all you know
strengthening the Epsilon and the
Epsilon is in the exponent so it's
exponentially stronger as we go from one
unit to the other and and therefore
harder to achieve in practice the one
unit that we've been using uh in our
production system is the user level unit
because we feel it's the most meaningful
one in the cross-device Federated
learning setting but it definitely isn't
the only one and you know we should be
thinking a lot about these things
so in the in the context of cross-device
the way we apply DP uh at least
classically the way we had been applying
DP in a centralized way is we would clip
on device first through the local
training take the model update clip it
in L2 sense to bound user contribution
and then you do an unweighted average of
the clipped updates across devices and
then you would add noise typically
gaussian noise on the server so you have
to rely on the server in terms of adding
that gaussian noise so it's very simple
in some sense to to at least apply but
the devil is in details how you analyze
the Privacy guarantees and flaws
Precision issues ETC a lot of things can
go wrong and they do go wrong and and in
fact one thing typically we rely on in
such a system is what's known as privacy
amplification via sampling which is if
the adversary does not know who
participated in what round it's adding
uncertainty into the out of the
competition and therefore boosting the
privacy and if that sampling process is
nice like uniform sampling of some sort
we know how to analyze and attractively
you know calculate the Boost in the
Privacy whereas for more complicated
sampling patterns it's difficult to
quantify how much of a boost we are
getting
but you know if you compare the
unamplified to the Amplified versions of
DP Federated average you'll see
especially at smaller values of Epsilon
things like four or two or less the Gap
in performance is Big so we really need
to get that amplification so that we can
get good trade-offs this is just a
simple language model an lstm trained on
the stack Overflow data set an expert
prediction model
um so you can see that this is something
that's quite important for us to be able
to make meaningful promises to to the
users
and so this is a big challenge for cross
device because the population itself is
not fixed there's user coming in and out
offline and online and and uh the
availability itself varies during the
day uh there are certain criteria that
devices need to satisfy so that they can
check in and become eligible and um it
happens to correlate with a lot of
things especially you know the time of
the day and so you'll see these patterns
in terms of who's available and they're
not fixed in constant patterns and so
there's no way for the server to do that
uniform sampling or even to push that
sampling process to the device and do it
reliably while ensuring that the
training continues to uh to to to
progress at the pace that we want it to
be without significantly slowing down
the pace of training so this is the
problem that we have tackled uh two
years ago
um in this line of work that we're
calling dpfdrl and the main idea here is
that instead of thinking of DP in the
context of training ml it's basically
One-Shot application of the gaussian
mechanism so independently in every
training round we would apply the
gaussian mechanism we would look at this
problem as some sort of a streaming sum
problem and we would apply correlated
noise across these rounds and in a sense
that prevents us from heavily relying or
relying at all on amplification via
sampling so the idea here is that if you
just unroll the the training uh uh
equation uh just the dpfatf update
equation you'll notice that all you need
here each update can be written as the
prefix sum of gradients and this is a
classical problem it's a studied widely
in the differential privacy literature
there's a lot of ways to go about
continual observation or releasing
prefix sums with DP and um really all
we've done is we've built on this long
and Rich line of work took it adapted it
to the context of machine learning
machine learning introduces certain uh
interesting constraints in terms of
participation patterns
um and so there's things that you have
to take into account and lots of
optimizations to to be done but if you
do it right you can you can essentially
relax this assumption that you need
uniform amplifi uniform sampling
so Jung is going to give us a very nice
overview of what we've done in this
space and especially in the context of
deploying this for gboard language
models
so then you know we start thinking about
how do how do we combine these
principles together so if we're we're
happy with what the progress that we've
done on the individual privacy front how
can we do extreme data minimization plus
individual privacy going back to that uh
you know vision of giving DP even with
respect to the server and this is where
we start relying on multi-party
computation something like secure
aggregation which is a very complex
protocol we cannot you know uh summarize
it uh fully in in one talk there's
papers on it this is just two papers
from our team but there's plenty of
papers before and after uh so it's a
cryptographic protocol that ensures that
the server only gets to see the sum of
these high dimensional vectors and
nothing other than that it operates over
uh integers
um and and specifically over finite
groups that's going to be important
um it's not a it's not a simple protocol
It's actually an Interactive four-stage
protocol so there's a lot of details
that I'm just hiding in the slide but
for the sake of the stock we're just
going to treat it simply as a closed box
and so then one thing you could ask is
well can I just take this beautiful
clothes box plug it in and make sure
that the server only gets to see the sum
of the clipped updates in every round
and then apply this DP ftrl mechanism
and the answer is yes and this is
definitely an improvement over what we
had before because now the server can
only see the sum of the clipped updates
but we still have to rely on it in terms
of adding the score related
noise and this is something that we've
also talked about in in this recent
paper that's on archive and maybe John
will touch on it as well
but you might want to do more can we
actually uh relax the trust even more
and push the noise Edition all the way
to the device so so can we not have to
rely necessarily on the server even in
terms of adding that noise and and this
is you know this is something we've done
and uh looked at but it comes with a lot
of challenges some challenges around you
know uh secure aggregation operates over
a finite group what does it mean to add
something like uh continuous gaussian
noise we need to think of discrete
versions of these distributions and we
need to be able to reason about sums of
high dimensional discrete uh noise
vectors and tightly bound their privacy
loss uh and and do accounting
efficiently with that uh and we might
want to also trade off uh communication
and we don't want privacy to depend on
communication if anything maybe accuracy
will get hit by a little maybe a lot if
we're extreme on how many bits we're
communicating but we want privacy to not
be a function of what you know how much
we're communicating so you know in a
nutshell what we've done on this and you
know this is summarized in a series of
papers
um a lot of people including Thomas here
and uh the crowd have contributed to uh
these uh Works
um you know we start off by clipping as
we did before but then you know we want
to transition from a clip to vector and
RD to something that's integer that
lives in a finite group so what we have
to do is we have to do a random rotation
to move from an L2 geometry to an L
Infinity geometry and then in an L
Infinity geometry we can discretize so
we do some sort of randomized rounding
and we need to hear capture precisely
what happens to the L2 Norm of the
discretized vector so we have good
proper handle on that and then we can
add integer noise and combine that with
secure aggregation we can take a module
operation to ensure that all the entries
are in a finite group and then some on
the server we just unscaled and
unflattened of course I'm hiding all the
details of how we analyze such a thing
which is really you know interesting and
pretty but it works the the you know the
types of distributions that we end up
using are things like the simple
discrete analog of the continuous
gaussian and uh something that's called
the scalan distribution which is simply
the difference of two independent
poisson random variables IID across D
Dimensions both of these can be thought
of discrete approximations for the
continuous gaussian and they are very
well behaved if you put it all together
you'll get a performance you'll see that
if I increase the number of bits per
parameter so if I get if I use something
like 14 or 16 bits per parameter I could
get a performance that matches exactly
the centralized continuous gaussian
mechanism so even though I'm doing it in
a distributed way while using secure
aggregation with only about 14 bits per
parameter
so after this work we uh asked ourselves
you know fundamentally for this
mechanism how many bits do we need to
communicate from the device to the
server and if you Analyze This discrete
gaussian mechanism for example you'll
quickly notice that you need something
linear and D bits uh to be transmitted
to the server and that's often a lot if
especially if D is very large and the
secure aggregation protocol has both
compute and communication costs that
scale linearly in that parameter so can
we reduce it so we embarked on a study
to see if we can reduce that to
Something sublinear in D and it turns
out that you can but only if Epsilon is
actually very small so so so this is the
condition that we were able to derive
which is you know it depends on the
cohort size the number of vectors we're
aggregating across the users so that's N
squared times Epsilon squared if N
squared Epsilon squared is smaller than
D then we can get gain otherwise D is
really a fund mental quantity that we
need to respect otherwise we wouldn't be
able to match the performance of the
centralized gaussian mechanism which is
the reference here the way we achieve
this is simply via linear compression so
linear sketching sparse random
projections ends up actually being the
scheme that achieves this fundamental
trade-off so we're lucky that it's
simple simple to apply on device and
simple to also decode on the server and
finally I'll just show you like you can
get pretty good compression schemes this
is again the stack Overflow Network
prediction data set you'll see we can
get about 3x reduction at a noise
multiplier of 0.5 so the Epsilon does
not very high
so with that I'll stop here but there's
plenty of questions in the space namely
the biggest open question is that these
distributed uh
DP mechanisms work really well if we
want to distribute DP fetav we still do
not know how to do them for the more
advanced stateful mechanisms that add
correlated noise so this is really just
matching the performance of DP Fed Up
We're relying on amplification so with
that I'll hand it off to Kunal who's
going to tell us more about the
two-party model
thank you